hey guys this is andrew for trading
senses.com i've been working as a
professional trailer for the past
six years in hong kong and i've created
my youtube channel a few months ago
i want to show you guys in my videos all
the different tools and techniques
that we can use as protraders to make
money on the markets
so i must use technical analysis which
is a set of tools
that allows you to predict the price
action
so in today's video i want to show you
how to do it with gamestop
let's get into it
[Music]
so this is gamestop child guys so i've
just done the short term analysis i was
showing you that on the hourly time
frame
you know you had this kind of behavior
that is very helpful when you you know
your day trader
that when you spot for example this
moving average that is
supporting the price perfectly guys you
know this is the kind of stuff that is
very precious
when you work in training this is giving
you
very good signals because you can see
that the reactions were perfect in the
past all right
so i'm not going to go through this
again here i want to take a step back
so i'm gonna go on the longer time frame
the farmers
for example i want to take a step back
and try to make the different scenarios
and see
what is happening all right so the first
thing that i
i see is that there is some bearish
momentum on the short term you know when
you have a look at the news
game stop overvalued and vulnerable to
the digital threat
gamestop stock syncs as market gains you
know you have this kind of stuff
do option traders know something about
gamestop uh we don't
i mean you know the only thing that is
on the option market that is very
animated is that the volatility is very
high
so this only means you can see it like
here for example
so you go on yahoo finance you type your
maturity here
and you can see for example the 690
strike which is
the highest strike you can have on the
30s of every maturity
you have an implied volatility of 315 so
it's very very big it's like around
you know 20 daily moves for the coming
uh two weeks so it's a lot you know
because
of course you won't have everyday game
stop moving by 20 percent
so it's an average so it means that
someday it can move by 50
so this is what options traders are
expecting and usually it's associated
with
a bearish market but here in this
situation let me explain you something
that is called
divergence so if the market is shifting
momentum you always have this kind of
signals all right
that are showing you that the market is
out of steam that
the bears are in control you know on the
longer time frame because here bears are
in control on the short time frame but
who is in control on the longer time
frame
that's the question i'm having and
to answer this question you can use very
basic stuff guys
so let's go on the daily timeframe
it's kind of obvious here
you can use what we call divergence
right so a divergence
is actually two opposite signals
coming from the price action and a
momentum indicator
so for example the macd and what
you want to see if
there is no shift in the momentum is for
example the price action going lower
with the macd
going lower as well right so there is no
divergence
you want to see the price action going
lower with the volumes going
lower as well and here for example this
is exactly what we have
so if i go on the four hours time frame
and
analyze for example this
move so the volumes are not very clear
here but you can see like
volumes going lower
price action going lower as well i can
start it here if you prefer
so no divergence the macd going lower
volume is going lower price action going
lower this all makes sense
here the price action is going higher
and the macd is going higher as well so
the volumes
are here for example not going higher so
here you have the divergence right
so you could have a divergence on the
short term on the volumes
because you can see the volumes are
going lower here
and the price action is going higher
right just
in this time so this is divergence for
example
so this is a good example to show you
guys so you
you didn't have the divergence on the
macd mac degree
was going higher uh price action was
going higher but the volumes were going
lower
so this is showing you that the market
is out of steam for example and here
we had this correction so
interesting to notice then if i take
one more step back so daytime frame
so we have same thing guys i
you know now i'm analyzing the larger
degree
wave accounting so i take
from this high to this high so i don't
need this one anymore
price action going lower
volume going lower max
going lower so no divergence on the
bigger time frame
so this is telling me that we are still
in the same momentum as we were
when we arrived here which is bullish
so of course doesn't mean that on a
short term
we won't see for example gamestop going
to 110 it just means that
if we go to 110 there's going to be a
lot of buyers
because we are still in this bullish
stance
that's why on the longer term i am
bullish
and as i showed you guys on the short
term i'm looking for some
more bullish signals and we need to
break
this downward sloping trend line that is
here so now around 160
and then we have 175 to break as well so
this uh
all this area between 160 180
is the area we want to see broken for
the the bullish momentum to really come
back strongly in the game
and then finally my counting would
be good i mean you know i'm looking for
the third wave
and i don't have it you know here i have
the first wave
then here i for me have my second wave
that is complete
so this should be a third wave but guys
the third wave is
always very impulsive all right and then
four and five
and this doesn't look to me like a third
wave
during a third wave the volume is
increasing this is the strongest wave
with the more volume
so this doesn't look like a third wave
because the volume is going lower and
for example we are doing right now if
it's a third wave we're doing a one two
and we're looking for the third wave in
the third wave and once again
so here i had something good
so for something like this i had
something good uh when we had the strong
rebound with some more volumes but then
right away it got rejected so something
is telling me that this correction
is not finished yet and i'm i'm
wondering
uh if actually the second wave was here
or if the second wave is simply
here we could have here a wxy correction
so i showed you the second scenario
x y correction and
then this is only the one two so then it
would make more sense
with the third wave that needs to be
more impulsive and then we're gonna have
the third wave
and then four and five the fifth wave
guys i remind you goes to 800
okay something like this
so this would make for me more sense but
for this to be true the correction needs
to be
deeper so we need to go you know
sometimes it's good to correcting more
it's good to go for this buyers that are
waiting at
lower levels you guys maybe want to buy
the dip
and you won't buy it at 150 120
you will for example weight 210 you know
this is for example what i would do if i
need to buy the deepon gamestop i
wouldn't buy it
above 110 so maybe you know
the price action needs to go lower for
the bullish momentum to really really
come back strongly and to
have this third wave so this is
something i'm looking for but once again
so this is the bearish case because once
again i'm bullish on the long term if
this changes
guys i would let you know i would try to
spot if i see some divergences
or anything that shows me that you know
the price action might actually
are really really good over for example
another indicator is to look at this
volatility as long as we have a very
high volatility on gamestop you know
especially on those very out of the
money strikes
it means that the market is very
animated that there are a lot of buyers
and it means that we're still in this uh
bullish development
the signal on the option market would be
given for me by a volatility that gets
really hammered this implied volatility
so this is something you
you guys can uh check so for example you
know
taking utilities of april you know is to
to show
to actually have good information you
can go on july
you know it's more stable and you check
the for example 800 strike
you know so here it's at 190 and you
keep an eye on this if this for example
goes to 150
like a 50 drop in the implied volatility
of this
july 800 cold strike this would mean
that you know option traders don't
believe
actually it would go that high it shows
a lot
of information on the option market it
it means that they don't need that much
protection
uh to sell the school options to retail
so it's something that i keep an eye on
as well because i'm an option trader and
i know that this
is you know usually some early signals
that you can have in the market
and just to conclude i want to show you
guys all right so this is my bearish
case
and my bullish case is still on the
table so i told you it's like the one
two is here and this is actually three
three four five and in the third wave
here we are just doing a one
two as well all right
three four five and then now let me zoom
in so yeah guys this is idiot wave
counting you know i
it takes me a lot of time to prepare all
these scenarios for you guys
but i like to do it it's something i'm
used to to do
and by the way if you guys want to know
more about all the different rules that
you need to apply
when you use illiad wave principle so of
course you can find it on the internet
everywhere you can read the book as well
which i did
wrote on by presh trend first but it's
very
tough to read i come from a financial
background i'm
you know very at ease with all these
kind of things
and it was a struggle for me so that's
why i decided guys to make for you a
training
that you can have for free of course
everything is for free
by clicking on the link in the
description of this video and you're
gonna receive
the access to uh this video
so here it's still possible we are in
this scenario
and this is a one two you know three
four five all right so we would have
something like this
so now i take and get rid of the biggest
one
so you just see what is happening here
so this is something that could happen
as
well and the third wave usually breaks
out some very important levels
so for example here the 175 so this is
on the table but like i said
it's a bit weak for me uh to get
the third wave suddenly that impulsive
so i'm expecting maybe
some more correction so that we can go
for some liquidity sitting at lower
levels
and you know using all this power to
actually
break out those levels very impulsively
that's what we need to have guys
and once again i showed you many times
uh the big
big open interest let me show you again
quickly
on those uh strikes upside strikes that
you have
on gamestop so you can see guys like the
open interest that you have on this old
high strikes and gamestop and for
example here
so i'm updating the stuff regularly and
you can see that for example on the 690
690 30s of april you know you have this
9
000 options so it means the multiplier
is 100
so it's around 1 million shares
equivalent
sitting at the strike so of course for
now the delta is zero but i showed you
guys this
many times if we go to say
500
this delta it's only 16 because the
maturity is very
short but if you go to 800 then this
delta is uh
75 so it means that the option traders
need to buy
one million shares to edge the books so
this is what is the gamma on options and
this is creating a lot of bullish
momentum and
upside so yeah that's it for me i hope
you guys enjoyed this video so just to
sum up what i've said
here i don't see any divergence on gm
stop price action i'm still bullish on
the long term
i have no problem in my uh different
scenarios to see a price action going
back to 110 i would still be bullish
because i don't see
those divergences and i think actually
it could be a good thing
to get back some liquidity sitting
endless levels and helping the price
action to be very impulsive on the
upside
to actually trigger this bullish
momentum that is hidden
on the call options we have on this very
high strikes
thanks to the gamma those options have
so
if you enjoyed this video please don't
forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys